hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
you may be thinking why on earth is
there another ps+ video in the middle of
the month
well if you've watched Sony's e3
conference you will know as of right now
call of duty black ops 3 is available to
download it's free to everyone who's a
PlayStation Plus subscriber from now
until the 11th of July like always
you'll keep the game as long as you
subscribe to PS Plus just in case you're
a bit skeptical you will receive the
campaign the zombies mode and the
multiplayer portion no strings attached
the game was released in late 2015 and
received damn good review scores with
GamesRadar & IG and giving it nines and
above if you haven't played a cod game
in a few years this is worth a try
especially the zombie mode give him
black ops 3 away now is most likely an
attempt to get as many of us on the
black ops bandwagon before black ops 4
releases on October the 12th in fact
there's a carrot on the end of this
stick those that pre-order black ops 4
will receive maps for black ops 3 that
includes fan favorite Maps jungle slums
summit and firing range what do you
think gonna download it anyway I'll stop
wasting your time I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you